oprah winfrey is revealing her new
highly anticipated book club selection
only on cbs this morning galen oprah
spoke to the author last week about the
book
oprah calls the most important read for
all of humanity right now it provides a
new way of seeing
racial inequality in america
hey vlad we are still here in the santa
barbara bureau
and the oprah who owns the santa barbara
bureau where we've been for the last
month
call me viewer chief that's good oprah
that's good i know you're excited about
all your books
but this one is different because you're
doing something that you've never ever
done before
first of all okay go ahead this is the
86th uh oprah's book club selection but
this
is the most important book yeah
the most essential book the most
the most necessary for all humanity book
agreement that i have ever chosen and
the book is called
cast by by isabel wilkerson not just
isabelle wilkerson but
pulitzer prize oh isabel wilkerson
hello isabella isabelle give yourself a
round of applause hello
hello my heart sings just to see you
here
it's so good to see you isabel i was not
exaggerating when i said i've never seen
oprah so excited when she said
that she wants as many people as
possible to read this book she ain't
playing what are you doing
i'm buying 500 books of my my own and
i'm sending them to
every governor in the united states i'm
sending to the top 100 mayors in the
united states i'm sending them to the
100 top uh ceo
of companies college professors and
college professors
uh the top 100 colleges and why are you
doing that and i'm doing that because
i think as i just said this is a book
for all of humanity and it is
necessary for people who are leaders in
our country
to understand the origins of our
discontents
and what caste really means so we
haven't given you a chance
isabelle do you want to say anything
it's about it this book
is the bomb because it's interesting
about cass because i never thought of
the u.s
as having a caste system but after
reading your book
i see it so clearly and i'm not sure i
like what i see isabelle so
explain set this set the scene set the
tone for what you wanted to do in this
book
this is not a book that i wanted to
write this is a book that
that that compelled me that called to me
that
i felt i had no choice but to write it
and so i
ended up working on this because it
seemed that there were things going on
that only cass could really explain we
have actually
made so much progress when it comes to
things that we consider to be
you know traditional old school racism
of the klansmen
of uh you know the late 19th century and
early 20th century and so now we are in
a very different place
how is it that we have these situations
that in which there are these videos
coming out
so so many that show uh
african-americans uh for example moving
about their regular day and someone
comes in and then
calls the police on them for sitting at
a starbucks waiting to be
waiting for their friends how is it that
we're seeing these things
so there's something else that is
percolating underneath
all of what we can see what's so
extraordinary is the comparison of
the american caste system the system in
nazi germany and also in india
how did you come to that tas is
something that we applied to
to india the original caste system so
that was the first
the first place i was going to look and
then after charlottesville
charlottesville pulled me into another
direction because
in that moment we saw the symbolism of
both the
uh confederacy and nazi symbols
coming together converging in the
rallies who had themselves made this
connection and that
propelled me inspired me to go and look
at the history of germany
and how do they remember their past what
have they done in the intervening
decades to
reconcile that past and atone for it and
what can we learn from it one of the
best things that i kept talking about to
oprah i love the analogy of the
house the house talk about the house
oprah why we like that so i want you to
talk about the house
because it's so dead it's so dead on it
the fact that you came up with that
house is a metaphor because for
for for our country and for me it
represents
america as it has been as it is and what
it can be
and everybody who has a house
understands exactly what you mean
i present our country as an old house
and when you have an old house you know
that there's always work to be done on
it
and when after a rain you do not want to
go into that basement sometimes because
you don't want to know what you might
face there
but whatever is there you're going to
have to deal with whether you wish to or
not it's
never going away until you address it i
have to say
that the chapter on the euphoria of hate
that is
the defining chapter for me and you end
that chapter
by saying that it's much harder to look
into the darkness in the hearts of
ordinary people
with unquiet minds needing someone to
feel better than
whose cheers and votes allow despots
anywhere in the world
to rise to power in the first place it's
harder to focus
on the danger of common will the
weaknesses of the human immune system
the ease with which the toxins can
infect succeeding generations
because it means the enemy the threat
is not one man it is us all of us
lurking in humanity itself
whoa drop the microphone isabelle
wilkerson there you go
back after spending uh an entire
afternoon in one of the many many
museums that
uh have been set up in berlin as ways to
to educate people about what had
happened in hopes that it would never
ever ever happen again
and it seemed to be that it connected
all of the all of the challenges that
humanity has faced over time
and that is to the desire or the impulse
to divide and to rank and
separate and the the need i think that
we have now to transcend these false
barriers
and to see that we have so much more in
common than we've been led to believe
can you just say this what was it like
when oprah called you and said she had
chosen your
the phone rings you pick up the phone
and it's it's the voice that is
recognized all over the world
hi isabelle sopra but no gayle
the first time i've called a book
usually i i've called authors over the
years and saying
i'm going to choose your book and
sometimes authors cry and they're
excited it's the first time i call an
author and i was crying
were you yes you were crying i was
crying because i think i'm
so moved by this book what you've done
with this book it's so amazing yeah
it's true it's true well it's coming out
it's coming out today i can't wait for
people to read it
all of humanity needs this book thank
you read this book
thank you isabel wilkerson thank you so
nice to meet you
thank you wonderful meeting you can't
wait to meet you in pison
hey vlad oprah's going to send you a
book now i'm going to send you a book
hey youtube jeff
i'll put you guys on my list you too
jerry i can't afford that
jeff is a big book reader you probably
do not but jeff glory is a big book
reader
books coming your way
i did receive my book so thank you very
much that was of course gail and oprah
from our santa barbara bureau
as they mentioned cast the origins of
our discontents
is on sale right now guys this is one of
the most
compelling non-fiction books of the 21st
century i'll go as far as to say
in the 20th century it will be taught in
classrooms the same way joan didion maya
angelou
up from slavery it's going to be in the
pantheon
it works i was saying we got an advanced
copy vlad i know you had started i'm
almost halfway through and i just think
it it feels like a history book
as oprah said it's almost a must-have
but it is a true history of all of these
different
things that have happened throughout
history and have led us to where we are
today
hasn't shared her copy with me um so i
don't have it but i did get to check out
some of it this morning and it does look
pretty fascinating especially this quote
that you just showed me
um where she says you know it's called
cast cast is the bones race is the skin
it is it absolutely structurally um
it's um it seems pretty fascinating